Here's everything I eat in a day.
Four months postpartum now.
As someone that loves to cook,
I always start my day off with a hot cup of tea.
Today it was some rooibos tea with milk.
I also hate the taste of water,
so I've been putting this hydration powder in my drink
and also taking my vitamins every morning.
This morning we're going for sweet,
so I decided to make a quick raspberry crumble,
and while that was baking,
I moved on to making a vanilla whipped cream.
This was one of my favourite breakfast I've made in a while,
and I ended up finishing the entire baking tray.
You guys know I need a midday beverage,
so I made a cherry vanilla iced tea today,
which was so divine. Had a bunch of Sun Gold tomatoes in the fridge,
so obviously we were gonna make some pasta.
I started by making my pasta dough,
and while that was resting,
I sliced up some shallots, garlic,
let those soften,
and then moved on to splitting all of my Sun Gold tomatoes.
Since those were cooked down,
I blended them up, started on rolling out my pasta.
We decided on some spaghetti today,
and once those were cooked,
I combined them with the sauce,
some butter, and kept adding pasta water until that all came together.
Made a little side salad with some arugula Blanche,
broccoli, Calabrian chili,
bread crumbs and a simple lemon vinaigrette.
I topped my pasta With a bunch of Parmesan cheese.
And that was lunch. We ended up having quite a late dinner,
and I wasn't in the mood to cook a bunch,
so kept it very simple.
And we made some caper chimichurri chicken wings,
and I also decided on a tangy slaw.
This dinner is going on my weekly rotation now,
since it was so good.
And I always have to finish off my day with something sweet,
so I had some caramel ice cream that I made the other day.